it was mentioned me that you got a new
drivers license recently yes and I was
thinking like I know you you or someone
who likes to pop for any occasion are
you the kind of person who can go and
just get a regular driver's license
photo made no no so I bought a very big
wig because I wanted the wig to fill up
the frame and then I wore two pairs of
eyelashes and then I stomped around the
DMV in these rhinestone sunglasses and
everyone was just staring at me I was
also wearing a leopard print I was doing
too much the way we actually have a
picture this is you on your way to the
DMV here's the problem you're supposed
to kind of look like yourself you're
supposed to be able to hold this up and
say okay yeah that's you it's an ID I
know it also says I'm 90 pounds you put
that down yes
and the lady did double take and I was
like I truly say something like what are
you gonna say right what do you guess
there's 90 pounds on me somewhere you
know never said I didn't say the full
weight of me you know I get double takes
my I told her my mail okay so did you
yeah because so I could see that did
they make it they make you take off the
glasses right oh yeah I took off the
glasses Oh could I kept the giant wig on
and then I asked the lady I was like how
do I look she was like gorgeous
that's nice because usually they take it
so fast she was very kind if you're just
kind to service people they're kind to
you do you know maybe not true not true
at the DMV no no I've tried I've been
sue I'm super nice and occasionally I've
had people just be like yeah that's not
working but you take a picture of me
when I'm just like no now listen you're
having more and more success all the
time are you getting recognized more
more often ah I don't really get
recognized until I open my mouth because
I have a strange way of speaking
apparently right and people recognize my
voice but truly at the DMV or not the
DMV at the airport
people recognize me as a TSA agent what
do they really think you're a TSA agent
if you're a black woman in the airport
you're a TSA I had one woman she went
through the metal detector and she came
back and she looked at me she was like I
forgot to take off my flip-flops and
then she handed them to me and then I
took them and I put them in the bin I
was like she thinks I'm a TSA agent then
I walk through she's like they make you
do that too and I said yes they do I
could have told her at any point but I
didn't work at the airport but I never
did you should have started it would
have been funny if you just hung out
there you probably could have crowded
people down then I go to jail and
there'd be like a terrible article
written on vulture about me